I will ready for this yes excellent
welcome to we can't hear you are you
ready for this
thank you all for that we have okay so
welcome to the secrets of scaling
interactive and insightful dashboards
with data studio bigquery pretty long
title I'm Felipe Hoffa I've been at
Google for the last seven years
Felipe is the developer advocate for
bigquery and I'm in-house Kazi I'm the
developer advocate for Google dealer
studio and I've been here for a year
yes welcome to Google mean thanks it's
been exciting happy to have you here so
a lot of people know me because I've
been doing bigquery and being the
developer advocate for it for the last
five years and I love analyzing data
I love visualizing need and we have a
lot of partners that help us visualize
this data but there has always been a
empty space in my life until that
estudia showed up true story
yes data studio is Google's business
intelligence / visualization platform
that anyone can use for free to build
scalable insightful dashboards and well
quick query makes felipe happy data
studio makes me happy and together we
would like to make the audience happy so
here we would like to answer this
question for you how can you get your
big data ready to visualize and share
with the world and the answer to that is
let's combine bigquery and data studio
but if you want to combine them there
are certain rules as when you want to
combine me and Minkus on a stage yes it
doesn't always work sometimes it does
sometimes it doesn't and you have to
follow certain rules so we want to share
with you our best secrets when using
both together yes
one thing is that everything we talked
about here today are all information as
of July 2018 so if you're looking at
this recording at a later date please
know that new information might be
available so yeah so YouTube people the
principles that we are going to show you
here remain
but the relationship with bigquery and
that estudio will only prove as my
relationship with minhas hopefully
hopefully here so let's get started
let's do some examples so we can look at
this dashboard that you built a few
years ago mm-hmm if anyone likes
football
I made this dashboard with all the goals
that happened last month and what I love
about this dashboard is that I was able
to put it on the middle of a medium post
so you have a dashboard in the medium of
a medium post exactly and it's
interactive so let's say you want to see
the goals from
your favorite team which would be Chile
Chile I am from Chile but Chile did not
play this year give me another one
Brazil cool so yeah this is interactive
you can show your favorite team and this
were the goals of the field Felipe there
are all these dots on the right side
what is the one on the left side or the
one on the left is an own-goal
belgium says obrigado but let's continue
sure so this is one dashboard that you
built in data studio from be creator and
publish it people are using it we have a
few other examples Wikipedia who knows
Wikipedia if you don't know it look it
for it on Wikipedia how many pages that
we have in our mouth or this year
millions millions billions yeah so in
this shared table I have all of the page
views for 2018 and this table has a
summary of pageviews per hour and this
table has already 31 billion rows more
than one terabyte of data and
visualizing this will be pretty
interesting and we are going to do that
next
what else are we going to look at today
Stack Overflow
you know Stack Overflow yes yes that's
where I spend most of my time so again a
lot of us spend a lot of time in Stack
Overflow and I want to see the most
current trends where are all the pages
going and
again I publish a dashboard or medium
it's interactive let's look for your
favorite tag angular angular angularjs
one of the top tasks is it going up or
down show fans who here thinks angular
is going up and who here things angular
is going down oh come on
ok angularjs is going down but wait a
minute
right below angularjs there is a tag
different tack called angular angular
yes so the angular team switch tag
exactly everyone is right it's going
down and up but angular effect
technology's going up and to the right
Oh
which is pretty good so we have also
other data sets like google ldq firebase
if you have your own data for Google
Analytics for our base for your app you
can visualize that by putting the data
in bigquery and pulling out that into
native studio and having a dashboard
exactly so it's pretty good you can also
use these techniques for private data
and we're going to show you a little bit
of that and the last years that we have
is a very interesting one it's a chrome
Eve X report the premiere at steam has
anonymized data for all the chrome users
who where you can basically see for five
million different URLs that actually you
website usage performance like how fast
does it take to for that website to load
and you have that data for five million
different URLs and you can look at it
from different countries by different
connection types and by different
devices okay so this is millions and
millions of observations anonymize and
share don't be query by the chrome team
and we you can look at three million
websites five million websites and you
can have looks like this sound and here
you can see how the Google's homepage
performance changed to the time yes so
from October 2017 to February most of
the times it was 80 percent people had
like a fast performance for the first
contentful paint but then something
happened in March it went down and then
is slowly go went back up again in June
2018 there was a regression someone
please
fix that pretty fast but the fun thing
is on one hand it's not easy to read
these queries because how do you query
anonymize data it's a little different
but you can make it everything as easy
for users with a data studio report yes
and we will show you how you can see the
same thing for your own website cool so
Philippe these are all big data sets
mm-hmm
I have a question for you what is big
data
do you know what we call big data Google
know what we call it data I see what you
did yeah all right all right I can get
behind the wheel of data we deal with
huge data sets all the time so what do
you use to deal with data we have
amazing tools inside Google we share
them with the world
one of them is bigquery we use it to
analyze terabytes of data everyone here
is familiar with bigquery okay oh so
many hands I think you might be at a
Google conference so it's because it's
awesome you can analyze a lot you can
use sequel it's scalable it's always on
it operates with your favorite data
science tools and you can share data
everyone has a free terabyte for queries
every month and it's ready for you to
try awesome
so maybe we can see an example yeah
let's look at an example of the query
page views of Wikipedia we were talking
about how many page views we have in a
month oh this is why we keep our website
secure yes and we are here on the new UI
for bigquery for those that have not
tried it pretty cool let's compare what
page got more page views which page do
we compare what the World Cup maybe we
can look at France and Croatia
okay let's compare France and Croatia we
have very saved will open up the query
the query is ready there cool and run
the query which one got more page views
France or Croatia we hear things France
got more page views Prussia all right
okay we have the results there
and Croatia go up to eight times more
view of five million views versus less
than a million and though this data for
last one month around exactly so the
question now is is this related to the
World Cup or not we don't know that
because we have to look into the data
this is just one number if you can do
this query maybe by day or by hour that
would give us more insight let's try to
find some correlation so can you
visualize let's first see that ready
okay hope we will run the query for by
hour uh-huh let's get the results by
hour and we will run this query in the
query for friends and crazy here we have
the results hour-by-hour here so the
problem with this is these are a lot of
numbers and from here you don't really
know what's going on you can't compare
this is where you need visualization
here comes a question how do we
visualize these results what's the
easiest way well you use data studio
let's see-oh status to you data studio
is Google's like I said VI and
visualization platform that lets you
build engaging and engaging reports and
dashboards it works like other key Suite
applications like sheets or Docs or
slides so you can collaboratively build
dashboards it's a turnkey publishing
platform which means you just turn the
key and it works that's it it has
built-in permissions model and it is
easy and completely free to use free
let's write it out alright so we will
take the same query you had
or this one so half of my business query
and go into data studio create a new
data source and there are a lot of
connectors in data studio that will let
you connect to different data sources so
we will connect to bigquery create a new
custom query take our project to sir
project the building project and we'll
paste the query we had and we were
looking at only two countries let's look
at all the countries all the countries
in the world cup okay do that one let's
do that and every country that
participated there let's see which one
got more page views now I will buy our
yes so we will this and we know that
this is hour by hour so pick this hourly
and create - so what data studio is
doing now is creating a live connection
to bigquery and pulling in the data you
have thousands of connectors almost
there hundreds hundreds and one of them
is a connector to bigquery right and
people can keep writing more connectors
until we have somethings yes this is the
now we're visualizing the results of
this query we'll make a line chart
mm-hmm a time line hour-by-hour and
thatís - is now going all the way to be
query to get the results again and then
pulling in the data mmm here you can see
the results for all the countries but I
only see 10 countries in a studio is
just picking new ten to begin with you
can just change this number you can put
in any number of countries you want for
example I'll just put in a filter here
mm-hmm
show me just France and Croatia all
right so filter is here we view it again
so it's now again populating the value
for the filters we will take right here
and France France so we already know
that Croatia I got more pages but when
did they get the pages yes and this is
taking some time because thatís 2d is
going all the way to be query analyzing
our huge table every
make the changes it will make a new
query and pull in the data again from
the query so as you can see Croatia got
these huge spikes at different times and
I let's see at what time this is around
9:00 p.m. and this is UTC UTC so it's
when the games were playing this is
basically when the semi-final happened
and the final happened so all the spikes
Croatia is getting is exactly when
either they were winning or they're
playing the finals exactly so
correlation is not causation but at
least we can see that that's when
Croatia was getting all the pageviews
and probably they were getting more
pages and France because less people
know what is Croatia but now they do
that's why they go to Wikipedia now this
was cool but a little slow because every
time we're going to be query we're doing
a round trip so can you make it fast you
can there are different ways of making
it fast and we are introducing a new
feature in data studio shortly it's not
available right now so this is like a
sneak peek preview we already have a
feature called Explorer that lets you
look at data in a more visual way and
you can drag and drop and visualize it
and along with that you'll be able to
materialize the data so whatever data
set you're pulling in you can take that
data so you can take the data and
materialized inside GCS and pulling data
from there and we can probably show a
quick demo of that
let's show a quick them of the future
feature so we will go back to bigquery
and we will run this query inside
bigquery again the new bigquery you guys
try it out now on beta open for everyone
running the query and I believe the
query ran and then you have this button
called Explorer in data studio once you
click this button it will take you
immediately from bigquery into data
studio with the query that you just
selected and let you explore this data
and we can try to recreate what we did
earlier so we will just get rid of that
record count and wurly by default it
makes it daily but let's look at things
hourly time series chart and
in views and this should recreate what
we did in the earlier but in the
Explorer view so it's pulling in the
data and what will happen is once you do
this you get a nice button here that
will let you materialize the data set so
you'll be able to click that button and
then that button will basically take the
data and put it in data studio and then
you'll be able to create very fast from
within either studio and you will stop
doing the round trips to bigquery so
where it takes maybe five or four
seconds right now it'll probably take
less than a second half a second to
materialize so that's how easily
materialized would work it will work
like just any other data source I can't
wait until we get the materialized
button will have some limitations it
will so it's a feature still being
developed it's not available right now
the workflow probably might be a bit
different there will be a hundred
megabyte limit me initially so because
the data will be materialized in out
storage you might also get some
limitations around scheduling you'd have
to manually update the data or there
might be scheduling options available
where you can set up for that data to be
updated every maybe one day or hourly so
we're still looking into it so that's a
great feature you can read your queries
it will materialize say you will
schedule them but what if I need
solution now you want to do scheduling
today yes I believe you have a solution
for that yes because I as I showed you
before we have published this dashboards
online and we wanted a solution that
didn't go through bigquery every time so
let's show them this is a Google
spreadsheet developed by Annie Lopez one
of our teammates and in this sheet I
just can copy any query and behind it we
have a script who here knows about Apps
Script awesome so if you don't know
about a script a script is google
scripting language that is a subset of
es5 JavaScript you can code on the web
UI or you can also call locally and push
the code into the web UI it works very
well with other other Google
technologies like Docs sheets slides and
Google APs and services like the query
so with a few lines of
code I can get a a script to query
bigquery and with no code I can schedule
a trip to go there every hour every day
whenever I want to run it awesome so
what did you do with this app scripting
sorry I scheduled to work every every
hour and I added three lines of code so
Astrid would materialize the result of
my query into Google Cloud storage this
is all it takes to materialize to be to
Google Cloud storage and then data
studio can read the data straight from
Google Cloud storage yes that is true
so this will work with scheduling
however there would be some problems
with that one is you still get limited
by that hundred megabyte data set in
cloud storage and this data is not
indexed it's like a flat file you get
pretty fast results with small files but
bigger files will not give you index
results so for that there are more
solution you can connect data studio
tomorrow sources in this case for a
bigger batch mode I use cloud sequel let
me show you them the dashboard here so
this is a dashboard that you haven't
published yet finally I will publish it
soon let me show you a preview this is
again stack overflow but in this case
I'm looking at the trends question by
question for every question in spec
overflow so you can see what what is
trending what are the most important
questions right now what questions are
not needed anymore and this ones are the
questions for bigquery one of the top
questions of this quarter and two
quarters ago was was getting the
application credential for Python
another big question is how can we cast
in bigquery some people are lost they go
to stack overflow and they keep going
there on the other side you can see the
trending questions things that are new
questions for our users how to move a
gate yeah string to that in bigquery on
the other side questions that are not
that important now and as you can see
this is a lot of data so putting it in a
database that gives me index of results
is a good way to serve this what is this
trendline on the left side oh yeah a
couple tricks when using data studio in
this
I managed to get a temperament you can
change the tack for anything else let's
say tensorflow
and say flow alright or JavaScript let's
see if javascript is trending up or down
on s2 you have a script okay anything we
can just jump anywhere here and you can
see that javascript is not getting any
more views but you can get this little
trend here and you can also see those
little trend lines there in each line
those we build using just some sequel
magic too and if you want to see how we
made them we did this as a collaborative
project on Stack Overflow so we have
looked for spark actually query and you
will find my answer and my GD years on
Mikhail's we got there don't know about
sequel they just drag and drop and make
beautiful visualization yeah so can you
tell us what you exactly did behind us
how did you set up your data Bible oh
yes let's go back to how we made this
with cloud sequel basically a happy
query and it'd be quite a run my huge
analysis reducing the data I store it in
cloud storage that can be imported into
cloud sequel which is my sequel in this
case and then thatís - you can read it
okay you have this whole pipeline where
you're getting data from bigquery
putting it in cloud storage and from
cloud storage is getting imported into
obstacle and data studio just uses its
native connector - cloud sequel to pull
in the data and the data is fast because
it's indexed and ministry has a native
connector to classical you don't have to
set up the firewall rules it just works
out of the box exactly so it's pretty
easy and then I could put any other
catch in the middle cloud sequel just
was just pretty easy for me for this
case okay what about private data well
because all of these we will looking at
public datasets but I want to bring
these principles also to my own data
here we can do that like we looked at
Stack Exchange data which be data but
you might have private data where you
want to use the data with yourself or
maybe it's an organizational data where
you want multiple people within your
organization to look at the same data
there the question also becomes that hey
and I use templates I have my private
data and I want to create a template
where all my internal users can use the
same template with my data or can I
create a template where different
private users can use the same template
with their data and the thing is yes it
is possible data studio lets you use all
the reports as templates and we have a
template gallery if we go to data studio
google.com slash gallery there's a huge
gallery with all different kinds of
templates available and we'll look at
one example so this is the example for
Google Analytics for firebase let's say
you have your Google Analytics profile
base data in bigquery this is a sample
visualization with someone else's data
this is an example data and you have
your own data set in bigquery and you
want to use that data set
with this dashboard so the way you do it
is you'd need the name of your project
so I will just take an example because I
don't have my own various project that's
the name of your the project you want to
visualize once you have permissions -
I'll go back and all I have to do is use
click click on this use template and I
will change and create a new data source
I know that data is in bigquery and I
know it's a shared project if you're
doing it for your own project it you
might have to go through your my
projects and go through that flow and I
will pick a project the shared project
name the data set is analytics and the
cable is events boom become events and
click connect and now it be finally you
created a connector for the pretty
template and now any template that you
look is data that you may have in the
similar shape you can use it for your
own data with data studio yes so this is
the sample data that we have on bigquery
it's using that sample data set but I
just connected that data to this
template and it's working well and this
is working and connecting straight to
bigquery and now we're in a similar
place like this is great for the data
analyst yes but if I want to publish
this so if you want to make this
callable for an analyst what would
happen is
let's say analysts would probably create
a direct connection from bigquery data
studio you write a query you create a
dashboard and you have the direct
connection and for the analyst analyst
can create a dashboard like this for
example based on the chrome you exterior
set but they would incur very little
cost depends on how many queries they're
doing so one analyst does 300 completely
unique queries so it doesn't use any of
the cash in bigquery or there so it's
completely any queries and on average 30
gigabytes of query size they will use
nine terabytes of big data big data and
then that would cost them $40 for an
analyst pretty cool now you are wearing
300 times 30 gigabytes of data that
might be a big table but the price is
reasonable everything is working fine
but then you want to polish this that's
where you might face some difficulties
but because let's say you take the same
dashboard you put it on a website
embedded somewhere in your medium post
and then suddenly hundreds of people are
looking at it so I'm just assume high
positive zero 500 visitors are coming to
your website they are there are four
different queries in your dashboard and
each user is looking at the dashboard
six times again around 30 gigabytes of
size you end out with 350 terabytes of
data usage in bigquery so the first
thing you have to do when you start
playing with this if you have to have
some kind of caching there yes or turn
on well yes that's a good point first
line of defense is this yes there on
your cost controls in bigquery so you
will not wake up to any surprise these
are pretty easy to use you just earned
among and everything you will not wake
up to any surprise because your queries
will be contained but then I still want
to put this dashboard line and I want to
have all my cost content there is a way
to do it you know what we could do is
everything that we just looked at you
have this caching mechanism you have
templates and you have scalability we
can put all this together into one
solution that is how can you use it go
from complex data to a scalable cost
effective - within five clicks by using
community connectors with the community
connector we will be able to encapsulate
all of this logic
without having the users need to know
all of districts yes
comedy characters are again written in
app script their connectors for Google
Data studio you basically define a few
functions and then add your connector to
data studio and then data studio can
pull the data through that connector and
you can implement your own logic for
caching or permissions you can all add
all without you have the flexibility to
build any logic you want yes for example
we took the chrome UX data set from the
crew exterior said you kept me and
potentially build a dashboard that looks
like this but we wanted to give the
users more flexibility so what we did is
we created a workflow that looks kind of
like this we have the initial data set
in bigquery so we did we every month we
do an initial level of aggregation and
we create a smaller bigquery table you
go from the 30 gigabytes table to listen
to much better yes so that is our first
level of cache then for every URL once
per month we cache that URLs data into
cloud faster which again has a free tier
and from cloud fire store every time
someone wants to look at a dashboard
containing that URL we pull in that data
into Apps scripts cache abstracts cache
is not permanent it will be alive
maximum from maybe a few minutes to 6
hours so if you're using the connector
to connect with that data you get very
fast performance but it's not persistent
so you have to pull it again from fire
store so we take all of that we take the
cache data and we add it to a custom
template and then then we have this
community character that you can use in
da studio so that estudio connects to
the connector you calculated all of the
logic there and it goes on every level
of catch that you want exactly but as a
user I want to know my own website how
do I use it so if you're the user you
don't see any of this you don't worry
about any of this all you get is one URL
so you get go to this URL and we'll just
hyperlinked it we go to this URL that's
it you get a new interface where you
have to add in your website so let's try
Wikipedia Wikipedia or any of your
favorite websites we have 5 million URLs
so we'll add Wikipedia we will add this
origins to be modified connect allow
this is a public URL whether you are
right now yes and so what this is doing
is it's going into bigquery pulling in
the data so right now it went into
bigquery pulled in the data put it in
cloud firestore pull the data from fire
store put it in the app scripts cache
and it's now ready to create the
dashboard so we create the report and we
already have a template attached to it
so the user makes puts in their URL
makes five clicks and they end up with
their own dashboard for the URL oh and
this is their own dashboard it's not
like a shared dashboard that different
people are viewing it's their dashboard
they can go in they can change things
edit things they can do whatever
basically they want for example I will
put in a comparison here so I can take
this same thing I will take the URL and
take this one copy it paste it so I have
two things side by side for the same URL
and maybe I'll compare with with a
different website any website any
website anyone in the suggestion Google
come and the users can do this whoever
this is the user just waiting to this
they can do the same thing so you have
side-by-side comparison of your website
with any other website that you picked
and this is real-life usage data it's
not even like sample data this is total
Chrome anonymous usage statistics and in
this case the connector is using your
credentials yes like any user can create
a new instance of the connector the
credentials are privately stored there
yes the creations we're using is on a
service account so whoever created the
connector is bearing the cost so the
users who are using this connector they
don't have to worry about having a big
query account or they don't have to
worry about cost because they are not
incurring it and you don't worry about
the cost either because you built all of
these caching layers yes so we can have
a look at the cost now if we go back
initially we were incurring this much
cost and this much data usage for
disconnect
but if we implement the new model for
caching what ends up happening is it's
the same 500 users but you get less than
100 for that per dashboard view because
you have everything cached and your
query size becomes 2 gigabytes so it's
less than one terabyte of bigquery the
usage which is in the free tier and it's
less than 10 gigabytes of firebase usage
which is again in the free tier so your
cost becomes zero that's how you can
encapsulate all of this and create a
complete solution but what about
permissions oh good thing is if you want
to create a new committing actors we
have this code lab you can go to this
code lab and learn how to create your
own community character using Apps
Script it should take you about 15
minutes to 30 minutes
and you can create connectors to any web
api or external services and it's an
amazing code lab because meme has about
it let's talk a little bit about
permissions because we have private data
we have enterprise data there are levels
where we want to secure our data so what
can we do about it and even if bigquery
has some permissions inside exactly
bigquery has a Google permissions model
of who can read write or modify tables
and you can make your data available at
that level you can if you go to the next
Richard you can see here like you can
add users by email or create Google
groups to make easy to manage them or
with any domain or for all of them to
get the user for public data or even you
can create views that allow people to
see your data but only through a view
which is a pretty cool model but you
don't even need to share your data
bigquery if you do it on data studio yes
data studio also has several layers of
permissions if you create a data studio
report you can share it with other
people just using the drive permissions
so you can share it with a selected
group of users you can share it within
your entire organization you can also
share it with everyone who has the URL
and you can share it either for viewing
permissions or for editing permissions
you can also take this report and embed
it so let's say you shared this with
everyone and then you can take this that
report and embed it in a medium post
like Philippe did you also get
permissions at the data source level so
when you create a data source
and you add the data source to a report
you can put in either viewer string
shells or owners credentials what that
means is if I create the report and I
put in owners credentials and then I
shared that report with Philippe and
Philippe views the dashboard Philippe
will see my data but if we enable viewer
screen shells when Philippe views the
dashboard Philippe will see Philippe's
data and I will see my data and I can
control if people want to see the my
data that I share with them or if I can
only they can only see data they have
the permission to see the permissions
get passed all the way through that
estudio into your source yes and the
good thing about community connectors is
that using committing actors you can
implement any kind of permissions model
that you have if you have your own
permissions and own credentials it up
you can also flow that through community
connectors and add that as a layer on
top of all of this nice and it's pretty
cool that's how our partners create
their own connectors yes most of our
partners have their own credentials
which will flow through this and then
they will basically know which user is
using the connector and then they can
show that user their specific data we go
into all of these four data sets the
Wikipedia page views stack of new trends
Google Analytics for firebase and chrome
X reports that was pretty interesting
for us I guess yeah hopefully was
interesting for you too let's go to our
takeaways so bigquery is really really
awesome to analyze terabytes of data and
data studio is more awesome because it
lets you dashboard all of your data for
free exactly but if you want to put them
together
you want some rules in between there
needs to be some something in between
the caching layer something in between
exactly and there are ways that you can
do this that materialized will you will
have soon and will be pretty easy to use
and you can use popsicle you can use
cometa connectors adding a cache Inglot
layer will let you avoid having like
exploding number of queries in bigquery
yeah so that is basically the end of our
presentation if you want to know more
about bigquery or data studio you can
view the subreddits you can ask
questions on Stack Overflow
if you want to know more about me and
ask for
human Twitter if you can't get enough of
Felipe follow him on Twitter your
feedback is our data and we love data
yes thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]